y ahí no se puede esperar más que
continúe la farsa la represión que ha
venido caracterizando todo este clima
preelectoral pero que de alguna manera
también se han ido construyendo ya que a
lo largo de casi quince años se tiene
daniel de estar en el poder de ahí la
importancia de la denuncia de la
importancia del papel también de la
comunidad internacional desconociendo
esta farsa del próximo domingo del mundo
los resultados en donde se va a
proclamar también gobernante de nuevo y
desconociendo la legitimidad del
gobierno que de ahí va a ser bueno y
esto es precisamente mencionaba
brevemente el papel de la comunidad
internacional pero con mayor profundidad
que cree usted que puede hacer la
comunidad internacional frente a los
resultados de los comicios y dependiendo
de qué pase en estas elecciones
miren por lo menos también me parece más
allá de que se puedan garantizar
resultados efectivos
después del 7 de noviembre a mí sí me
parece que al menos la comunidad
internacional no puede esperar a que
llegue el 7 y el día al día siguiente
preguntarse y ahora qué es lo que sigue
es el y ese sería el peor mensaje que
estarían recibiendo los autócratas del
mundo que como en el caso de daniel han
venido desafiando día a día a plena luz
del día los distintos llamados y
resoluciones que se han emitido en el
seno al consejo de derechos humanos se
hicieron la asamblea general o el
consejo permanente de la oea pero además
las consecuencias de lo que daniel ha
estado haciendo para ser muy grave sobre
la estabilidad política de centroamérica
sobre todo el hemisferio en materia
humanitaria y con graves secuelas desde
el punto de vista democrático de ahí que
si la comunidad internacional tiene
todavía mucho margen de maniobra
mediante la imposición de sanciones
individuales y económicas y como también
mediante una estrategia diplomática
concertada y consistente y si los
organismos multilaterales todavía tienen
un margen de maniobra a futuro como
considera usted que ellos han actuado en
un pasado como califica las actuaciones
de ellos frente a nicaragua
yo quiero ser muy franca la acción más
allá de los ojos los técnicos de la oea
que han sacado su trabajo como la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos el departamento
operación electoral a través de todos
los informes que han venido confirmando
las graves circunstancias que vive
nicaragua los órganos colectivos han
actuado de manera tímida de manera
tardía y de manera ineficiente
y esto a pesar de que estamos
conmemorando en américa latina en el
hemisferio los 20 años de la carta
democrática
de manera que en dos o tres días después
del 7 de noviembre el 10 de noviembre
tendrá lugar una nueva asamblea general
de la oea
algunos países en la obligación de
pronunciarse y deberíamos ver la
aplicación clara y contundente del
artículo 21 de la carta democrática que
tiene que ver con la suspensión de
nicaragua y una acción colectiva para
presionar al régimen si los organismos
internacionales siguen nada más
aprobando declaraciones esta situación
va a seguir y el otro frente que quiero
mencionar es la acción de los organismos
financieros internacionales no puede ser
que sigan dándole oxycontin oxígeno
financiero a un régimen que está
violentando los derechos humanos de
manera tan flagrante
mientras sus padres en materia de
derechos humanos están condenando esta
acción de manera que de nuevo hay que
alinear esas decisiones financieras a la
minera internacional las sanciones
nacionales de algunas naciones
importantes con lo que los organismos
políticos y multilaterales han venido
opinando sobre nicaragua